yes
stupid
Democrats are giving Trump and
Republicans plenty of political
slaughter after another good night at
the ballot box for the president first
up is New York Governor Andrew Cuomo he
is raising eyebrows for these comments
about America we're not gonna make
America great again it was ever that
great we have not reached greatness we
will reach greatness when every American
is fully engaged we will reach greatness
when discrimination and stereotyping
against women 51% of our population is
gone
the governor clarifying those remarks
saying America is great and will reach
her full greatness with full equality
there's also Democratic congressman
Steve Cohen apologizing after saying
this about Republican Senate candidate
she's currently congressman Marsha
Blackburn that's okay congressman Maxine
Waters birthday yesterday
here's her wish my biggest birthday wish
would be that we're able to get a leader
of this country who represents us who
has a respect of all of our allies I
would wish that we could remove him from
office
actually the president wished her happy
birthday today and said anyone who sees
her should wish her a happy birthday -
meanwhile congressman keith Ellison
scored a victory in the Minnesota
primary race for the state's attorney
general just days after domestic abuse
accusations against him surface Ellison
is also being criticized for past
appearances with controversial Nation of
Islam leader Louis Farrakhan so let's
start with Andrew Cuomo I found
something of interest Greg really a tale
of two Cuomo's in 1994 Mario Cuomo his
father in the most eloquent speech of
his career it was at the time said
America is the most magnificent mosaic
that is America and then Andrew Cuomo
said America was never that great hmm
yeah interesting fact
so Andrew and Chris Wright brothers yeah
did you know that the movie Dumb and
Dumber is based on them interesting fact
look okay here's the big point you look
at all this inflammatory rhetoric and
you got to realize that we're being sold
a bill of goods about this era being
super divisive and awful and evil I was
at the Nixon Library over the weekend
the first thing when you walk in you see
the first year which is 1968 in the in
the museum you walk through there war
riots domestic bombings domestic terror
internal external threats assassinations
communists were ascendant during that
period the only thing missing was
asteroids and Rosie O'Donnell it was a
terrifying era so people have to realize
that this is not an era of great
conflict right now we're in an era of
peace and prosperity but we're being
sold that this is the worst possible
time to be alive when in fact you know
pace Cuomo America is great Ahmet we are
its spirit we are we've never eradicated
more poverty in history we have more
people working we have the highest rate
of optimism what tool in what almost two
decades so the idea that I think I think
he's biting into the media world that
this the of an apocalyptic and but
actually all you got to do is go back to
68 and see when you were there and you
said if social media had been around
then the country may not have survived
yeah
if Twitter and Facebook were around in
1968 we wouldn't be around now let me
ask you about this Jesse because we're
seeing this several times where a
candidate now 2020 hopeful goes out and
says something quite provocative like
Elizabeth Warren said about the police
at Netroots nation then they end up
having to walk it back they backtrack it
or they end up apologizing are they all
just a goodness like demolition derby to
see who can knock each other out well
historically you'd think the Democrats
are ready to to win because that's what
usually happens in a midterm like this
and they're ahead a little bit on the
Congressional ballot so you just think
they just keep their mouth shut
nominated normal centrist candidates
raised a lot of money and the anti-trump
they can't contain themselves though
because their base is so crazy and
frothing at the mouth so much they get
carried away at these events and they
say the things they think they're
radical left-wing base wants to hear and
that's when you get things like Andrew
Cuomo who had to walk this back less
than 24 hours later I agree with Greg I
think America was great when we defeated
the Nazis when we won the Cold War when
we put a man on the moon when we
invented the internet and the iPhone and
all that stuff they don't forget tang
then Tang tang